now this rhinoceros viper bears a
warning on its head for those who know
the species this giant arrow screams
contains lethal venom look out Danger
Danger I'm going to bite kill and eat
you
whereas this vine snake is more subtle
it has a super bright dayglo tongue that
contrasts with its dull colored
magnificently camouflaged body come on
could you tell the snake from the tree
branch if you weren't looking for it it
can play possum and lay in wait for prey
but when it itself becomes prey that's
where the tongue comes in suddenly this
green tree branch sticks out it's bright
orange tongue that says ya mess with me
yeah sure if you want a great big tooth
full of poison thing is the vine snake
is not venomous but the Predators don't
need to know that nice trick but here's
the trickiest snake of all the
two-headed snake you talk about crafty
defense and office
this is the tale of the two-headed snake
the tail looks more like the head than
the head the false head quote keeps
guard sitting on the coils while the
real head sneaks off looking for food
now here's the real head it has no
distinguishing features those are on the
tail this means that a predator is
likely to attack the tail instead of a
head thinking the tail is the head
instead of the head being the tail just
to complete the confusing illusion the
tail actually mimics the defensive
strikes made by the head of a retreating
snake so ends the tail of the snake with
a head like tail and a tail like head
[Music]